Steven Spielberg's 'Lincoln' leads the pack with 12 Academy Award nominations,...
...including Best Picture, Best Director, and Best Actor for Daniel Day-Lewis.
Few of the other contenders could pose a threat to the 16th US president,...
...but there can be surprises.
Director Ang Lee's 'Life of Pi' trails with 11 nominations...
...and has all the ingredients for an Oscar in the Best Picture category.
Lee's phantasmagoric cinematography enhances the story of an Indian boy adrift at sea with a Bengal tiger.
The superb editing and music make for an on-screen magic...
...and the Academy's voters may be swayed by this fairy tale.
Tom Hooper's remake of 'Les Misérables' follows with eight nominations.
Hugh Jackman would be eschewing for Best Actor...
...if Daniel Day-Lewis were not running.
And despite her barely adequate vocals,...
...Anne Hathaway is considered a favorite for Best Supporting Actress...
...for her depiction of the dying Fantine.
But the sets are stilted, and Russell Crowe's 'Javert' is weak.